[Music]
it is Mark Consuelos and his 21 year old
son Michael it's a Teen Choice Awards
yesterday and it was just announced that
Michael was cast as a younger version of
dad on marks hit show Riverdale and you
can tell why well oh it could be his
twin and mom Kelly Ripa congratulating
him too with this note quote I would
like to take this opportunity to remind
you and your siblings that Asher
fiduciary's we are hereby entitled to
10% of all future earnings here to which
or something like that in quote how
hilarious really I love it Kelly just
one of many Hollywood moms having a
proud mama moment sure those are tears
but we're pretty certain Kristen Bell
was in a good place as she witnessed a
milestone event five-year-old daughter
Lincoln's pre-school graduation the
comedy star tried to play it off
captioning her video with don't worry
guys I'm having a great time I'm not a
mess or anything
her next post okay I was lying before
please can help the 38 year old mom
recently told us she may have met her
match with her two little girls
oh they're stubborn as all get-out okay
but maybe they get that for me
meanwhile we are loving little Luna
legends roar proud mama Chrissy Teigen
shared more pictures of the family
vacation in Bali and Luna sundress and
sandals look is to die for and how cute
is this
she calls every animal mama or Dada
depending on how masculine or feminine
they look
and finally Victoria Beckham
seven-year-old daughter Harper is
spicing things up good question Harper
the mother-daughter duo shared some
downtime while on family vacay and
Indonesia where she's been watching her
mom's 1998 movie spice world on repeat
Victoria says the little as Beckham is
obsessed with the spice bus and now she
wants a little Gucci dress just like a
mama the mr. Gucci dress the garden